[Music]
kate andrews is our economics
correspondent she edits the spectators
daily covert 19 update email it is one
of the
biggest covered newsletters in the world
she joins me and now okay talk us
through where we
are with the vaccine in britain now i
saw the health secretary matt hancock
guy
get quite emotional uh about it he
clearly
thought this was a turning point yes he
he got
teary on breakfast tv talking about this
turning point and it is a turning point
andrew i think we can definitively say
that every day now we are
taking steps to be closer to protecting
the vulnerable in the uk
margaret keenan was the first person to
get the pfizer jab
on tuesday she's turning 91 years old
next week
this is one jab of 800 000 that are
meant to be administered in the coming
weeks that's 400 000 people
that are going to be inoculated and this
jab from pfizer is thought to be
effectively 90 this javed visors thought
to be 95
effective um so i think it's safe to say
that we are getting
a lot closer to protecting our
vulnerable but there's still a lot of
outstanding questions
as to the timeline how many vaccines the
uk is actually going to procure
how many more are going to come online
and how
we continue to learn to live with this
virus because
we're far away from saying that
everybody is safe
how seriously do we take these reports
of two nhs workers had a
quite severe reactions to the fisa
vaccine is that just
that's what happens there are a few who
do or is it more serious than that
well when pfizer was running its safety
tests they did
find that roughly one in a thousand
people might have had
an allergic reaction this is something
that can happen with all kinds of
vaccinations including
the flu jab there are warnings about
allergic reactions
i think the concern around this one it's
two nhs workers who had an allergic
reaction they're now thought to be
recovering
it was a short-term reaction it was by
no means fatal uh but the concern is
that the uk regulator
has now updated the guidance after
people started to receive
the jab and i think it goes to this
broader point of how officials need to
be
really honest and transparent and
communicative
about the data and the safety around
this vaccine
polls across the uk show that certainly
over 50
of the uk uh residents plan to take this
vaccine 60
70 depending on which pole you're
looking at and that's that's pretty good
data
and for those who are skeptical it's
usually not because they actually have
anti-vaxxer opinions but they just want
to know more about the safety
so i think you know incidents like this
speak to the fact that officials really
need to get out there and communicate
about why these jobs are safe the slight
risks that can be involved but there's a
great piece on the spectator website
right now from dr mark
toshner talking about how the risks are
extremely low and why it's a good idea
to get this vaccine
right well that's worth worth reading uh
kate
bring us up to date now on the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine the united kingdom
has bought
already a hundred million dollars is a
lot more than it bought uh on the fisa
one
but where are we with that when do we
think
that can be rolled out so if the oxford
vaccine were to come online we were we
would more or less have enough
doses of this vaccine to go around
certainly
to protect the vulnerable and those in
older age groups it's where the uk has
invested
most when it comes to these jobs but
it's becoming increasingly
complex when oxford first reported on
its efficiency rate it said it was
roughly 70 percent
effective but we found out uh when that
number was broken down
that it was 62 percent effective for the
large cohort court that had a certain
kind of dose given and then it was 90
effective
if the jabs were given in different
doses and so now there are questions and
the landsat has done a big report this
week
as to what a uk regulator can actually
approve
some of the questions are around age
perhaps they might approve it for the
under 55s
the 90 deficiency rate was only tested
on those under 55s
it's thought that they may need to go
back into a phase three
trial uh but the landsat highlights that
if this vaccine were to be between 60 to
80
effective its authors think that you
would still need certain kinds of social
distancing measures
uh ones that we know the prime minister
and i'm sure many people
perhaps the vast majority in the uk
would really like to throw out the
window
as soon as possible the idea of a
vaccine is that it is supposed to be
a silver bullet so one that isn't a
silver bullet is not going to be looked
as favorably on so there's still a lot
of outstanding questions around oxford
if and when it comes online it will be a
game changer as i said because hopefully
we could really speed up that timeline
for getting this vaccine out there and
injecting
lots of people but if it doesn't come
online for a while it does slow down the
process
the uk has invested in the pfizer
vaccine the moderna vaccine which
hopefully comes online soon
but by and large it's really relying on
oxford
and finally the economics of all this we
got the latest uh
uk gdp figures today showed the economy
growing for the
sixth consecutive month but it also
showed that growth was beginning to
peter out
uh by october nothing like the growth
the bounce back after
the horrendous uh fall in the economy in
march and april it would seem
looking at these figures that although
the economy may have been a bit more
resilient
than some might have thought it could
now be stagnating through november
into december and that we really need
the roll out of these vaccines
early in the new year if we're to see
life back
in the economy again by easter early
summer
is that correct i fear it could be worse
than that andrew we saw the economy
start to stall in its progress in august
which was arguably the most
open month of the year when it comes to
covert restrictions the ability to
socialize and for shops
to be open and one of the reasons it's
stagnating is because
we've learned that if certain
restrictions are in place there's only
so much that an economy can
really recover but i think it's going to
do worse than stagnate it's very likely
that when we get november's figures
we're going to see another economic
contraction
albeit not nearly as big as what we saw
in april but england's second lockdown
and the force
re-closure of shops and non-essential
business is bound to have a bad impact
on the economy
now a lot of these forecasters say the
good news is that if
vaccines come online if we are
inoculating millions of people in the uk
by next spring things could we could be
in a much better position rolling back
those social distancing measures
and some forecasters have suggested we
should look to their optimistic
scenarios now
not their central scenarios which
usually on average show
the uk economy recovering by early 2022
as opposed to the end of 2022 and that
that is a big and meaningful
difference but it is going to require a
lot to happen with vaccines in a
relatively
short period of time and i think when we
look at the trajectory of 2020 because
we
we know the vaccine's not going to have
that impact this year
uh you're going to see not a v-shape
recovery not a nike shape recovery but
actually quite a wonky w
because we are likely to have that
second economic contraction
which i'm just going to contemplate a
wonky w
doesn't look good economic correspondent
father the spectator
thank you for being with us on spectator
tv today now china has been vaccinating
its population
with unapproved vaccines since july
the estimate is that a million people
have been vaccinated
none of these jobs have received
regulatory approval
that may be why state media has been
relatively
harsh about this vaccination program
cindy you
is the spectators broadcast editor she's
host of our chinese whispers podcast
which if you want to know what is
happening in china is a must listen and
she writes about the vaccination program
on our coffeehouse website uh this week
cindy
welcome uh to spectator tv just tell us
a little bit about what's been happening
then
i mean a million people is not a lot in
a country the size of china
nobody's really talked about it what
kind of vaccine is it
why a million who's doing it what do we
know
so andrew starting from the beginning as
you said this started in
july that was when china introduced this
legislative
loophole based on who emergency response
to ebola outbreak
which was basically saying you know in
an emergency situation you can vaccinate
frontline health workers frontline
transport workers and so on
what the new legislation has said in
china though is that if you're going
abroad to
high-risk countries you can also get the
vaccine
so what that means is that the top
producers of vaccines in china there are
three of them saino farm
which is a state-owned company sono vac
which is a private company
and kansano which is a military
developed one since july they've been
injecting people so cyanofarm has been
injecting its own company employees
some of them are huawei employees as
well who go abroad
do these foreign contracts in different
countries and then some of them have
even come back and got into trouble with
uh with a border control in shanghai
because they had antibodies that they
were detected
and so cancino has been injecting
soldiers
we don't know much about the injections
of these two companies because they've
been keeping relatively
quiet about who they're injecting and
how many or they sign a farm claims to
have injected nearly
a million people what i've been looking
at in particular is sino-vac's
vaccination they've been doing this in
jersey on
province which has some 57 million
people as you say one million is a drop
in the ocean for that
um and the requirement there uh is to go
abroad
or if you're one of these front-line
workers what has happened is that on
social media this has caused something
of a millennial
uh ferrari because all people 20
somethings who
study abroad something of a rite of
passage for young chinese people
these days they're all clamoring for the
vaccine um
and in most of joseon province you have
to be a local resident in order to get
the vaccine
but in this one tiny city of one million
people evil
you can get the vaccine as long as you
provide plane tickets some kind of proof
that you're going abroad
and so on social media everyone's
recommending evil as a place to go
how do you get on the waiting list um
how much does it cost
and all that sort of stuff because
they're not getting much guidance from
state media because
as you say national state media really
hasn't touched it at all
you'd think that this would be something
that global times the very jingoistic
nationalist
tabloid paper will be having a field day
on that china started vaccinating so
early
but they haven't and i think the reason
for that is because these vaccines
are in phase three trials the only
reason they're allowed to be ruled out
is because they count as emergency
vaccinations
two questions cindy is there any
evidence of uh
untoward reactions to this vaccine i
mean
do we have any idea how this vaccine has
performed even though it hasn't finished
its full trial
yet and and if the chinese authorities
do have confidence
in it despite the trials not yet been
completed
why only a million people i think those
are good questions andrew so
on the first one the uae which is one of
the first countries in the world to be
rolling out sono farms
vaccine has said that it's 86 effective
but
none of the data has been released and
that was only yesterday
uh so we there's no you know peer review
for that there's no
verification process for that they claim
that no one has had adverse reactions
but one student i spoke to one
20-something-year-old who
studies in london but is in beijing when
he got vaccinated he didn't
leave contact details they haven't
contacted him since so
i don't know how these companies would
know if anyone did have an
adverse reaction because they're not
tracking it as far as i can see
i guess if you're more systematically
getting it because it's a place of
work then there might be more of a route
there more of a mechanism
and you know i think that china hasn't
wanted to do a mass roll-up because it
wants to see
how this vaccine goes china doesn't have
a great track record when it comes to
food and drug
safety viewers might have heard of the
2008
milk powder scandal where melamine
infused
baby formula hospitalized tens of
thousands of babies
so since then china has done a lot of uh
work on re
finessing that system but it was only
two years ago
when another vaccine and and not any of
the ones involved here
was find over a billion dollars for
putting out
default for putting out 40 rabies
vaccines so china doesn't have a great
record on it
i think if i was sitting right now i
wouldn't necessarily want to put my
face on these vaccines before they're
approved
and so that's probably why it's only had
a million people it's only rolling out
in one province
so far although more may follow by the
end of the year um because they're
trying to see
what's going to happen with that
interestingly though last week's i know
farm did apply for regulatory approval
and so i wonder if the western vaccine's
progress has kind of
you know jolted them into waking up a
bit they could have done well they could
have
encouraged them to speed things up if
they if the
stage 3 trials are successful and if if
it gets
a clean bill of health is the chinese
state on standby
with massive stockpiles of this vaccine
i mean is it ready to roll this out
in huge numbers and even to the extent
that it might
think of exporting or licensing this
vaccine
around the world absolutely so as well
as china starting emergency vaccination
as i mentioned uae has also started to
give an approval for
emergency vaccinations so sino farm is
already exporting
to the uae countries from pakistan
to indonesia to brazil have been
striking deals with china to get these
vaccines and
the interesting thing about the chinese
vaccines all three of them
are that they don't need to be in a
particularly cold temperature they don't
need to be minus 70.
they just need to be at a relatively
easier temperature so for the developing
world
because it's going to be a mass produced
by china with its cape capacity
and also b because it'll be easier to
store that would be a much more
preferable option
for poorer countries to deal with than
say the oxford vaccine
so so in that sense it is going to go
global um
within china um there's a national
procurement scheme
and so one public health expert i spoke
to said that this might be why
companies are so keen to roll out their
vaccines now before they get approval
because once they get corrupted into the
state scheme they might not get a say
over their prices
so they might as well start cashing in
now but that's just his theory
all right cindy you spectators broadcast
editor also
the author of our podcast chinese
whispers always worth listening to
thank you for joining us at cindy and
that's it for this week
thanks to our other guests and once
again to our very special sponsor
charles stanley
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest firms on the london
stock exchange
[Music]
you